now joining us is gabby's mother nicole
schmidt and her stepfather jim schmidt
also with us gabby's father joe petito
and her stepmother uh tara is with us
nicole let me start with you as a mom
i'm look i'm just trying to stand back
and as a parent myself i have a son and
a daughter trying to put myself in your
shoes it's impossible believe me i i
understand that and i'm very sorry to
all of you for living through this
i'm trying to understand
why this boyfriend ex-fiancee ends up
back at his home in florida and will not
tell you where he last saw your daughter
why won't he
why
any human being with a soul
would be doing everything possible to
help you get the answers to find your
daughter and every day that passes now
it gets more difficult doesn't it
it's
scary and heartbreaking
i don't know how to describe it to be
honest with you we are we are running
out of time and um
we're scared for gabby we think she
might be in danger and we just we just
want him to talk just tell us where
where was she where did you leave her
you know i i wanted to just know what
happened and i'm getting angry now at
this point as you can tell i'm uh i'm
beyond frustrated
you know as a mother to another mother i
i beg his mother to
make him speak or at least for the
parents to say something
yeah let me go to joe uh potato gabby's
dad and let me ask you joe you asked the
right question you want to ask the
boyfriend where did you leave gabby
where did you last see her now you
suspect that this august 30th text was
not actually sent from gabby why do you
suspect that and what has been the
outreach to this young man and his
family in terms of will you please help
us find
the our daughter that you were with and
you took her van home
the the outreach
is i think
350 million plus people asking where's
gabby i mean everyone's asking you got
one person down doing it so in all
honesty
it's we're all trying to find find the
answer and the only person who knows it
is sitting over in their house over
there
and you can't have a more frustrating
situation i mean i mean think about it
look where we are you know everyone's
sitting here trying to trying to bring
gabby home and the only one who doesn't
care is the one who's supposed to care
about her the most
did you reach out to his family and say
can you make can you ask your son to
help us
can you ask him to to put aside
whatever legal advice why would you need
legal advice if you're not involved in
something nefarious
why wouldn't you put aside everything
when somebody's life may be in the line
here
it's
you know you're asking the right
questions and and we've reached out i
mean we've reached out on i can't even
tell you how many times in the media you
know and
now and we we're asking everybody you
know to continue looking because
obviously the three people or that live
in that house
just don't care
they can put whatever statement they
want out at the end of the day they do
not care it's as cold and as as cruel as
you could possibly be and they're over
there and so the rest of us and the rest
of the country
are doing everything they can i get
emails from strangers i've never met die
in the hell
i'm so sorry you know as a father i'm so
sorry nicole and jim let me ask you why
do you believe the august 30th message
was not sent by gabby and do you have
any evidence so do you know where that
ping came from because you can track
where text messages actually originate
from
i'm sure the fbi has that information
i'm hoping they do um we know as little
as you at that at this point but um
i know my daughter and if you do the
math we know that she didn't send it
because he was home september 1st
and they never went to yosemite they
never had plans to go to yosemite so
it's obvious
yeah
and have you re i don't know if this
young man's mother's alive is his mother
alive did you ever reach out to her and
say can you please help me find my
daughter
yes i reached out to her on friday
the 9th
or the 10th i'm sorry
i texted her i'm worried about the kids
i haven't heard from them and um i got
nothing
called left messages got nothing
she won't even call you back
nope
and and joe and tara you you've reached
out they won't call you back
no
we've called
on the 10th i can't tell you how many
times we we sent text messages we're
worried we're calling the police
uh i mean if someone texted me that
they're calling the police because they
can't find my
you know my son you know i'm gonna drop
whatever i'm doing to call me back but
i guess it's evident how they how they
run their uh their household compared to
350 other million people in the country
joe and tara what do you mean i was home
at that time
i'm sorry tara
she knew her son was home at that time
when we were texting her
at that point we didn't know
that that he was home
joe and tara what do you make of the
video that was released from the police
and this this this this encounter
uh they said it was more emotional and
not physical i guess they didn't see any
signs of any physical altercation
um what did could you glean anything
from that video
i guess i i i myself couldn't bring
myself to watch the whole video but
that's me all right and i understand a
lot of people have seen it and all that
other stuff but i get it
really what that does is that
yeah i get it but it distracts from my
main focus right now that video does
nothing to help me find my daughter
because that was on august uh 12th i
last spoke to her on the 21st so any
time after that when nikki spoke there
any time after that
is where we're concentrating on
so that that video is as
as as whatever you guys want to call it
as it can be
that distracts from everything that
we're trying to do
we're trying to find gabby that video we
got we got contact after that so to me
at that mo at this moment that video
doesn't mean as much it says to her
location well you asked the fundamental
questions where'd you leave gabby
where'd you see her last nicole and jim
let me ask you have the police gone over
that van with a fine-tooth comb
i believe the the police do they have
they have it in their possession uh i
believe they have
done whatever they had to do with it
again we don't have a lot of information
on on the investigation itself it's a
very fluid very moving uh investigation
unfortunately we wish they could divulge
information to us
but
they can't and we understand why
if anybody has any information please
contact the fbi uh i want to say to all
of you
i'm sincerely sorry we're all praying
for you for gabby to get home safely
hope he hopefully he'll step up and give
the information you need more hannity
next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else